Prof: Okay,
let's get going.
We're into the last segment of
the course.
We did evolution,
and then we did ecology,
and now we're going to do
behavior.
I think the sequence does make
sense,
because evolution helps to
explain how the things we deal
with in ecology evolved,
and it also explains how much
of what we see in behavior
evolved.
But I want to say at the outset
that the behavioral ecology view
of behavior--which is basically
expressed on this slide;
so behaviors evolved--the
evolved patterns that we see in
behavior should reflect things
that happen frequently to the
organisms in their environment,
and the way animals behave
should reflect the consequences
of behavior for lifetime
reproductive success.
That is really only part of the
biology of behavior.
If you really want to
understand it at all levels,
you have to understand how
behavior evolved
phylogentically;
so you need a comparative view
of behavior.
You need to understand this
issue, which is how is it that
behavior is adaptive;
is it, or is it a maladaptation?
But then you also need to
understand how behavior
develops;
that is, if we follow the
organism from zygote to
death--you'll see some patterns
of that today--how is it that
organisms learn?
How is behavior acquired?
That's a whole field in and of
itself.
And then finally we need to
understand the mechanistic
underpinnings of behavior.
So in that respect there are a
lot of different ways you can go
at it.
You can go at it through
neurophysiology;
you can go at it through
endocrinology.
There are many different kinds
of mechanisms that are involved
in triggering behavior patterns.
So what we're going to
concentrate on in this course is
primarily the behavioral ecology
approach to it,
which is well exemplified in
the book that you've got by
Krebs and Davies.
But these other issues are also
very interesting biology,
and I'm just indicating that if
you get interested in behavior,
there are lots of ways you can
go at it,
and there are entirely
different paradigms you can use
to analyze it.
So the five themes that we'll
approach--and these are the next
five lectures;
so this is a sketch of how the
course finishes.
Today we'll talk about foraging
and hunting.
Then next time we'll talk about
evolutionary game theory,
which is one of the major
analytical frameworks within
which people approach behavior.
We'll have a look at mating
systems and parental care,
and they are connected in
interesting ways.
We'll take a look at
alternative breeding strategies,
which are frequency dependent
breeding strategies,
often best analyzed with
evolutionary game theory.
And then we'll close with the
evolutionary and ecological
analysis of selfishness,
altruism and cooperation,
in animals and in humans.
So those are the five themes
that I have selected out of
behavioral ecology to emphasize
in this course.
It's an introductory course
and, you know,
frankly it would be great to
give you an entire semester just
on behavior,
because it's such an
interesting topic.
But I will signal that we do
have other courses in the
department on it,
and if you get interested in
them, they might be fun to take.
Okay?
So I'm going to start with
foraging by bringing back in
something that you guys
presented on that Friday,
which is the marginal value
theorem.
And this time I'm going to
apply it not to whether you
should fill your plate up,
your tray up,
in the dining hall full,
if you're going to the far end,
or just with a little bit if
you're going to be close to the
counter,
but to the issue of how long
you should guard your mate,
and indicate that,
in fact, the same intellectual
framework applies in both cases.
Then I'll give you an example
where we can actually do a
clever experiment to get the
foraging organism to tell us
what fitness measure it is
using;
and that's often a very
satisfying kind of experiment to
do, if you can get the animal,
which cannot talk,
to tell you what it thinks it's
doing.
Then I'll illustrate how two
different birds deal with risk.
Because a small bird,
at the end of a cold winter
day, is exposed to extreme risk
of dying overnight--and I can
tell you this is quite real.
Over the course of a normal
Connecticut winter,
I am often picking up the
occasional house sparrow,
or robin, or whatever,
which has died next to my house
because we've had a cold night;
so that risk is real.
Then I'll discuss a little bit
how predators shape crypsis and
conspicuousness.
But then the sort of--the thing
that you'll probably remember a
week from now is the part of the
lecture that deals with why hunt
in a group?
And at that point I'll show
some chimpanzees hunting.
And I want to warn you that is
not something where you want to
be bringing- eating the food
that you've brought into the
room,
or anticipating lunch,
okay, because this is pretty
gory stuff.
Okay, marginal value theorem.
The important thing about the
marginal value theorem first is
that it's dealing with foraging
in space.
And it's assuming you're
starting in one point,
which would normally be your
home, your nest,
your refuge,
your den, and you are going out
to another point where you are
looking for food.
And you have options.
You could either go to this
place or you might go to some
other place, when you go out to
get food.
So you have to travel to get to
that patch of food,
and then you have to search in
the patch,
and then once you start getting
food in the patch,
you accumulate it--and this is
a cumulative curve--
in a way that expresses
diminishing marginal returns.
So the harder- the longer
you're in the patch,
the harder you have to look,
basically because you've
already eaten some of the stuff
in the patch.
Okay?
So there are a number of things
to remember about this kind of
diagram.
One is the X axis is time.
Two is it's split up into
travel time and search time,
and at the point that you start
searching is where you draw your
payoff curve here,
because that's the point at
which you're going to draw this
cumulative payoff curve.
The vertical axis is some kind
of payoff, and it's assumed to
have a relationship to fitness.
Okay?
So it's going to be food,
or it could be mates.
And probably the clever thing,
the most clever thing about
this--and I well remember when
Rick Charnov first drew this
thing;
he and I were grad students
together, and he was in his
office and he was drawing this
thing on a piece of paper.
So I saw it before it was
published.
The clever thing is the nice
geometrical solution to the
optimality problem.
And the way to think of that is
this: here is the measurement of
time,
and the question is at what
point should you stop searching
in this patch and go on to
another one?
And if you imagine all the
possible lines that you could
draw,
that fan out from this axis,
it turns out that the one which
is tangent to that curve has the
highest slope.
Okay?
So the slope--I mean,
you can see that,
just geometrically from looking
at it.
Okay, this is the line which is
going to have the highest slope
of all of the possible lines
that you could draw that are
within this envelope.
And you can't go above this
line.
The reason you can't go above
this line basically is that
you're not getting any food
above that line.
This line is defining the rate
at which you can conceivably
accumulate food,
just by the ecological
constraints of that patch.
And so this is the maximal
point for the slope.
And then you ask yourself,
what is the slope?
Well the slope is ∆y/∆x.
Right?
∆y is the change that you
get, or the amount of payoff you
get per amount of time you spend
searching;
so it's the payoff per unit
time.
So drawing a line that way,
as a tangent,
maximizes the payoff per unit
time.
You don't have to write down
any equation;
it's just geometry.
Okay?
And that actually is the cool
thing about the marginal value
theorem.
Now I want you to imagine you
are walking through a field in
the Alps,
and there are some cows grazing
in the field,
and you look off to the side
and you see two biologists down
on the ground,
looking at a cow-pie,
and you wonder what the hell is
going on;
why do they have their noses
down in a pile of cow dung?
And the answer is they are
looking at this guy.
Okay?
And one of the biologists is
Geoff Parker and the other one
is me;
because I had this happen to me
with Geoff in the Alps.
Okay?
So a cow--let me go back--a cow
has come along and it has
dropped a pile of dung here,
and it has been rapidly
colonized by a bunch of dung
flies,
and because of that,
within about a minute,
a male will find a female and
they'll go into copulation.
And then the issue is how long
should the male stay on that
female before he jumps off and
goes to find another one?
You can measure how many of the
offspring of that female will
get fertilized if he stays on.
And this is the proportion of
eggs that he will fertilize,
if he stays on.
Okay?
So it's starting to look pretty
much like a marginal value
theorem problem.
You can set up the analysis as
search and guard time,
plus time spent in copula.
So this is his- how long it
takes him to search and guard a
female, and this is how long he
spends in copula on her,
and this is his payoff.
And now look at what the Y axis
is.
It's directly fitness;
that's a direct fitness payoff.
So actually this is the purest
form of the biological
implementation of marginal value
theorem;
finding a mate and fertilizing
some eggs.
Now the interesting thing is
that he jumps off about ten
minutes earlier than predicted.
Any ideas on why he might jump
off ten minutes earlier than
predicted?
It's actually a method of risk
minimizing or spreading of risk.
He cannot predict when the next
fresh cow-pie is going to hit
the ground,
and that's going to be the next
open resource which gets
colonized by females,
and he needs some time to find
it, because he wants to be the
first one there.
If he can be the first one
there, he'll get the best
female.
So he has to jump off this
female a little bit earlier than
this simple analysis would
predict,
just to hedge against the
problem of trying to be first to
the next cow-pie.
This problem is actually almost
quantifiable.
Of course you are measuring
some rather strange things.
You're sitting there with your
stopwatch watching as the
cow-pies arrive on the surface
of the pasture,
right?
But it's a completely
analyzable problem.
Now, so that's the marginal
value theorem applied to mate
guarding.
Now let's look at an experiment
that you can do with honeybees.
And this was designed by Paul
Schmid-Hempel,
who is a very clever Swiss
biologist.
And what Paul did was he built
a model in which he could
predict how long bees would
spend flying between flowers,
and how many flowers they would
visit before they came back to
the hive.
Okay?
And he had two different
measures that they might be
using.
So this is the optimal
relationship between how long it
is flying between flowers and
how many flowers you visit
before you fly back to the hive.
In one model he had calories
per minute, which is the usual
rate.
Okay?
In the marginal value theorem,
when you maximize that slope,
if you're measuring that payoff
curve in calories what you're
measuring then is maximal
calories per minute,
in the marginal value theorem.
Paul thought well maybe they
have another fitness measure.
They might be using calories
gained per calories spent.
So he built the two models,
and he had quite different
predictions,
and then he manipulated them by
gluing a little wire onto their
back and adding a tiny little
weight.
So he made them--you know,
he had a series of treatments
where they weren't weighted and
then they had a little weight
and then they had a lot of
weight.
And this is what they did.
This is the data, okay?
So it really looks like he was
able to get them to tell him
which fitness measure they were
using while they were foraging.
That's a very,
very clever experiment.
And this is the kind of thing
that you can do in behavioral
ecology.
It's possible to construct
situations in which the
decisions that the animals are
making are so precisely
constrained that you can get
them to give you an answer.
I am waving over all the
details in the mathematical
models.
Okay?
That's graduate student stuff.
But I think the essential point
is that you can do an experiment
that will get you to tell you
what an animal is actually using
as a fitness measure.
Okay, now two comments on the
problem of how to deal with
risk;
and this is the small bird in
winter problem.
And this was a nice experiment.
This is a Great Tit,
which is a European form of
chickadee, and this is an
experiment which is done in an
aviary, and this is a variable
environment.
Okay?
So when the experiment starts,
the food supply starts becoming
unpredictable in time;
and that's just a manipulation
that the experimenter is
imposing on the animal.
And as the food starts getting
unpredictable,
the bird starts getting fat.
That tells you a couple of
interesting things right there.
It says normally the bird
doesn't like to be that fat,
but it's going to get fat
because it sees that its food
supply is getting very
unpredictable.
And then the way that you build
one control into this experiment
is then to switch it at this
point into a constant food
supply so that the environment
just becomes nice and
predictable and the bird
relaxes,
shrugs its shoulders and says,
"Oh,
I can get away with getting
back to a normal weight,"
and drops its weight.
So that's one way of dealing
with it.
But there's another way of
dealing with it,
and that is that if you look at
this other relative of the Great
Tit--okay, this is a Marsh Tit;
it also looks a bit like a Coal
Tit;
it's a little bit smaller,
has a black head--
and you put it in a high
variance environment or a low
variance environment,
this one, it doesn't change its
weight at all.
It just packs on as much weight
as it can, by evening.
And by the way,
at that latitude it's getting
dark at 4:00 in the afternoon in
the winter.
So it's going up to just about
peak weight.
And you can see how much it's
losing by the next morning.
What it does though is it
stores seeds,
and if you put it in a high
variance environment,
it greatly increases the number
of seeds that it stores.
So one of these
species--they're very closely
related by the way;
it's interesting that there
doesn't seem to be much
phylogenetic component to this;
one of them decided to pack it
on as body mass that it carries
around with itself,
and the other one decided that
it was going to store seeds.
It may have something to do
with the risks of predation.
Big, fat birds don't get away
from predators quite as easily
as nice slender little birds.
Now what are some of the
consequences of predatory
behavior for the prey?
Well one of them is so-called
aposematic coloration;
and that is that if you're
carrying around something that
is going to poison your
predator, you want your predator
to know that.
You don't want--you know,
if you put a bunch of ham
sandwiches out in Saybrook
Commons,
and you've got cyanide in five
of them,
and it's in the interest of
those five cyanide-laced ham
sandwiches not to be eaten,
then you want a big warning
label on it that says,
"Do not eat."
Right?
Well that's what these are,
these warning colorations.
If you go out and you pick up a
warningly colored millipede,
and you shake it in your hand,
it will smell like bitter
almond.
And it's perfectly safe,
by the way.
There's not enough cyanide in
it to get hurt by sniffing it.
So you're perfectly safe
picking up and shaking a
millipede,
except you may feel a little
moral compromise at the act of
shaking an invertebrate nervous
system.
Okay?
But they will emit cyanide all
over your hand,
and it does smell like bitter
almond.
And of course the monarch
butterfly caterpillar,
which gets its cardiac
glycosides from milkweed,
will cause tachycardia in the
birds that eat it.
Tachycardia is a condition
where your heart jumps say from
a pulse rate of 80,
in a human--let's say if you've
been exercising a little bit you
might have your pulse at 80 or
100 or something like that;
with tachycardia you go up to
250 or 300 and you pass out,
because your heart starts
fluttering and it can't pump
anymore.
So that's what eating that will
do to a Blue Jay;
it will have cardiac arrest.
So it would take a few of them
to do that to you.
So I suggest that if you want
to try this one,
don't eat more than one.
Okay?
If you really want to get into
it, you're probably getting
threatened if you eat maybe five
or six of them,
or make a milkshake out of them
or something like that.
One can do experiments with
this kind of thing as well.
This is a situation in which
chicks, just regular domestic
chicks, were given different
colored baits.
Okay?
And in both of these situations
they were given seeds that had
been stained green or blue,
and they had been soaked in
quinine;
and chicks do not like seeds
that are soaked in quinine.
So they were both distasteful.
The only difference here is
that in one case the green and
blue seeds are on a green
background, and here they are on
a blue background.
And what you can see is that
the ones that match the
background continue to get
eaten,
and the ones that stand out
from the background start
getting avoided.
Okay?
So there's a bit of learning;
oh, I don't like to taste these
things.
But then they avoid the ones
that they see most easily.
And that's what's going on over
here.
It's this process that has
produced these colors.
Of course it can go in the
other direction.
If you, in fact,
are not distasteful,
and you want to avoid being
eaten, then often natural
selection will change your
morphology in such a way that
it's rather difficult to see
what you are.
Okay?
The head is here;
that's the end of the right
wing, that's the end of the left
wing;
there's a nice wing vein
running down the middle.
Some of these things are just
remarkably precise in resembling
a dead leaf or other things.
I think some of the ones that I
like the most are the praying
mantises that look like flower
petals,
and sit on flowers,
and grab things when they come
in;
they're very nasty.
Here's another one that's very
nasty;
same kind of thing, okay.
So this is aggressive mimicry.
These are the light signals
which are given out by different
species of so-called fireflies--
in fact, these are beetles--and
they have a light organ,
and you can see that there's a
species specific signal pattern.
Now normally you would think,
okay fine, they're just
dividing up the frequencies.
They don't need to have an FCC
to regulate which frequency they
use.
They're flying through the
night.
They see a signal over there
and they can say,
"Oh, that is another one
of my species,
I'll go check it out and
potentially mate with it."
So you might think,
oh, that's all just normal mate
behavior.
However, these are males that
are flickering,
and then they get a response
from a female.
Okay?
So this would be male-male,
female, male-male,
female kind of thing.
And so there are some that
mimic the light signals of
another species;
some females that are sitting
there saying--they're faking it.
Okay?
A male blinks,
the female can see,
oh, that's not a male of my
species, therefore I can safely
eat him.
So she goes blink,
with the signal of the other
species, he flies in,
and she chews him up.
In so doing she gets two things.
She gets calories out of him,
but in some cases she also is
absorbing a defensive chemical
that will protect her from
birds, bats and spiders.
So she gets a double dose.
She gets both calories and she
gets defense from doing this.
This kind of aggressive mimicry
is reasonably widespread,
and it has been evolved
convergently a number of times.
The one that always got me as a
kid is the saber-tooth blenny.
You know about cleaning wrasses
that come into the mouths of big
fish and clean the parasites off
of them and so forth,
and the big fish have evolved,
because this is a beneficial
thing,
to kind of relax.
And so you will see giant
groupers and barracudas opening
their mouths and letting these
little fish swim through them
and clean off their teeth.
Well, there is another fish
called the saber-tooth blenny
that mimics both the color and
the approach behavior of the
cleaning wrasse;
which is, by the way,
a sigmoidal dance.
It goes through the water like
this.
And so you see one of these
things coming up and you kind of
relax and say,
"Oh, it's just a cleaning
wrasse,
it's going to be fine."
And it comes up,
and if it's a human,
it takes a chunk out of your
thigh,
and if it's a fish that has its
mouth open,
it rips out a chunk of gill and
goes running off.
So this is the sort of thing
that led Darwin to think that
evolution just fills the world
up with things that are taking
advantage of every possible
opportunity;
and aggressive mimicry is a
good example of this.
One of the interesting issues
with predation and parasitism
and mimicry has to do with the
cuckoo.
And I want to mention it
because it really is an
interesting series of puzzles.
Okay?
So here's a cuckoo.
Cuckoos, by the way,
feed on caterpillar larvae,
and so they tend to disappear
from places where lots of
insecticides are used.
So they're kind of a canary in
a coalmine.
If there have been cuckoos on
the landscape and you can't hear
them anymore,
it means that intensive
agricultural practice has
probably wiped out the entire
large fauna of caterpillars;
so they like to eat
caterpillars.
And what they do is they go
around and they find a nest,
like a robin's nest here,
and they lay their own egg into
the nest.
And they have their whole
developmental program set up in
such a way that their baby will
hatch earlier than the babies of
the host species.
And its behavior is set up in
such a way that the first thing
that it does is--
you know, it's just a tiny
little baby bird,
and it's just hatched out,
but it has enough muscular
coordination and enough
behavioral complexity to take
the other eggs and shove them
out of the nest onto the ground,
so it's the only one left.
And then it sits there.
And it's got a very effective
feeding behavior.
It opens its mouth,
it gives all of the
morphological and behavioral
cues that say,
"Feed me,
feed me, feed me."
And the parents work really
hard, the parents of the other
species work really hard to come
in and feed it,
and you get a baby cuckoo out
of the nest,
instead of a warbler or
whatever.
Okay?
Well why don't the hosts throw
out the cuckoo egg?
There they are.
They're good parents.
They come back to the nest.
There's an egg in it that they
haven't laid.
Sometimes it looks quite a bit
like their egg,
sometimes it doesn't;
it all depends on which
particular host species it is
and how close that particular
race of cuckoo is to matching
the host species color.
Well there are really,
I think, two reasons,
but they may not be
quantitatively sufficient to
explain everything we see.
One is the source-sink
distinction.
The hosts can't adapt as fast
as the cuckoo because the
parasitized nests are sinks for
the host, and unparasitized
nests are sources for the hosts.
Most of the sources are coming
out of nests that have not had
cuckoos in them.
If a cuckoo has gotten into the
nest, it's wiped out that
reproduction.
Okay?
So the adaptation is to the
source, which is to the
condition without cuckoos,
and not to the sink.
But there's another issue,
and that is if you're just
starting to evolve the behavior
of throwing eggs out of your
nest,
and you're not very good at it
yet,
you can make a serious mistake
by killing one of your own kids.
So there's kind of a threshold
there that you have to get over.
You have to actually--this is a
behavior where you actually have
to be accurate and pretty good
at it, before it pays off.
Before you get good at it,
you are indulging in some very
costly behavior.
Okay?
So that's another reason.
Another reason that we don't
see the hosts throwing the
cuckoo egg out is that the
cuckoos may be moving on to new
hosts.
So it may be that the cuckoos
for say a hundred years
parasitized robins,
and the robins may
slowly--slowly,
because of these reasons--
start to evolve a response to
cuckoos,
at which point the cuckoos just
switch over and start
parasitizing warblers.
And they do that for awhile,
and they just keep moving
around among the different
species in their landscape,
so that they're always able to
stay ahead,
because their evolution is a
little bit faster than that of
the hosts.
So that process is hard to
observe.
And the egg mimicry isn't very
precise.
You can see here,
this isn't a very good match.
This is one kind of cuckoo egg.
There are some that are a bit
closer to robins.
This might be appropriate for
another kind of species.
The egg mimicry isn't very
precise, and it is still kind of
puzzling why the hosts don't
throw out more cuckoo eggs.
It's an interesting problem.
Now I'd like to talk about
hunting in a group.
And this is a situation that is
interesting,
both because we can quantify
the benefits of foraging styles,
and we can see whether or not
animals are actually doing what
is quantitatively best for them.
But it also addresses the whole
issue of why animals should
exist in groups.
And since we are a group living
and hunting primate,
this is a very interesting
thing for us to contemplate.
Now when an individual joins a
group, it's making a pretty
fundamental decision.
It's basically deciding that
the payoff it's going to get,
from the coordination of group
hunting,
is going to more than
compensate for the fact it's
going to have to share the food;
unless it's an extremely
confident dominant type,
it's going to have to share the
food.
Okay?
So what you see in wolves,
coyotes,
African hunting dogs and hyenas
is that all of these things will
hunt alone for little things and
they'll hunt together for big
things.
So go up to Ellesmere Island in
the Arctic, pop yourself down
onto a wolf study site,
and go out and look at the
wolves hunting.
And if they are hunting for
voles and mice,
which are about this big,
you'll see individual wolves
moving about the landscape,
trapping them with their paws
and munching them up.
However, if they decide to
tackle something like a muskox,
they will form up into a pack
and go into coordinated
behavior,
with a division of labor and
assigned roles,
to bring down the muskox.
And the muskox,
of course, have a
counter-adaptation,
which is a group adaptation,
and they form a protective
circle,
and they all face outward
towards the wolves,
and they defend themselves with
their horns.
Similarly for coyotes,
African hunting dogs and
hyenas.
With African hunting dogs,
they will be going after
usually small rodents or birds
or things like that,
on the ground,
but they're actually capable of
bringing down a zebra.
This is a dog which is this big.
You know?
A zebra is a horse,
which is this big.
And five or six African hunting
dogs, each of which weighs say
about 75 pounds maybe,
at max--50 to 75 pounds--can
bring down a 500 pound zebra.
So the interesting thing is
that they switch facultatively
from solitary hunting to group
hunting, as group size- as the
size of prey increases.
Now in chimpanzees--I'm going
to show you a bit of the gory
detail of chimpanzees in a
minute.
But before I do that I just
want to show you some of the
kinds of things that these
capture.
So we have wolves and coyotes
and hyenas and African hunting
dogs,
and these are pictures where
they have done a sophisticated,
coordinated group hunt to bring
down a big piece of meat.
Now let's see what chimpanzees
do.
<<Professor Stearns plays
a video>>
Prof: That's Brutus.
Brutus was born in 1952, August.
<<Professor Stearns plays
the video>>
Prof: That's an
important point.
They use seasoning,
a little spice from the weeds.
<<Professor Stearns plays
the video>>
Prof: So that's in
Christophe Boesch's study site,
which is in Tai National Park
in the Ivory Coast.
Those pictures were taken in
about 1990,1991.
I had been there in February of
1989, and I had been out on a
hunt with that same group.
I had had lunch,
which was by the way fruit,
with them.
I ate the same stuff they did,
but I was eating fruit,
not colobus monkeys.
Those guys are all dead now,
the chimps.
They died of Ebola and they
died of poaching.
However, a smaller group has
replaced them.
Of all of the chimps that were
in that group in 1990,
there is only one female who is
still alive.
But the group is back to about
oh fifteen or twenty;
at that point there were sixty
in it.
So let's look at an analysis of
why they choose to hunt in a
group.
Okay?
So the increase must more than
balance the cost:
sharing.
They do it during the rainy
season.
During the dry season they
crack nuts.
So these chimps actually have a
culture where they teach their
offspring how to crack nuts with
a hammer and an anvil.
This is true west of a certain
river in the Ivory Coast and
it's not true in the rest of
Africa.
And you can see that they hunt
a lot more frequently in
September and October.
And I was actually there and
saw the hunt in February;
so they weren't so frequent in
February, I was lucky to see
one.
But these chimps hunt a lot.
And if you look at the hunting
success as a function of the
numbers in the hunting party--
you can see on the top here a
comparison of solitary and group
hunts in the Ivory Coast in
Gombe and at Mahale.
So Gombe is Jane Goodall's
study site in Tanzania,
Tai is in the Ivory Coast,
and Mahaleis a Japanese study
site.
And you can see that they hunt
quite a bit in Tai,
and they do a lot more group
hunting there.
And if you look at the impact
of group size on capture
success,
you can see that the more
chimps that are hunting in the
group,
the more likely it is they are
to make a kill,
the longer the hunt lasts,
and the greater the degree of
collaboration during the hunt.
So this is team behavior,
where individuals have roles,
and they learn to play a team
role,
and they learn to do what is
good for the team so that the
team will have greater success.
If we look at success as a
function of group size,
you can see that the net--and
by the way,
this is now measured in net
benefit in calories,
and in order to calculate that,
you have to be able to estimate
how many calories a chimpanzee
is putting out,
if it's running along the
ground or climbing a tree or
something like that.
And so this is taken from
exercise physiology,
the estimates are taken from
exercise physiology.
And then you can figure out how
many calories are there in a
colobus monkey of a given size.
And it turns out that the right
number to have--if you are a
hunter you do better up until
you get to a group size of five;
after that you have to share
with too many others and the
payoff isn't so great.
If you are a bystander,
it's pretty much the same,
the curve mimics that.
And if you are a latecomer
who's coming in,
then normally you don't get too
much of what is caught.
So in this particular hunt,
Brutus led the hunt and he made
the capture.
So that was the chimp that you
saw going up as the blocker;
that was Brutus.
Brutus, by the way,
was the oldest male in the
group, and he also had a couple
of strategic innovations.
Brutus had figured out that in
competition with neighboring
groups--
and chimps do have wars with
neighboring groups--
if you were in a state of being
the weaker group and you were
being confronted by a big one,
what you would do is you would
go over and you would display at
the border.
They would come in,
and then you would quiet down--
and he got them all to quiet
down--and the pack of males
would run around the back and
steal a female from the back of
the other group.
And this caused such chaos and
disarray that they would
normally be able to overpower a
larger neighboring group by
using this sneaking behavior.
Just think of how much
strategic thinking it requires
to figure something like that
out.
And that was Brutus;
he was a smart guy.
And there he is right there.
So Macho was contending with
Brutus to be an alpha male--
there are two or three
different ways you can define
group hierarchy in chimps--
and Macho was trying to be
group leader.
And he was actually a very
collaborative hunter.
It's one way to sort of weasel
your way into power is to
collaborate a lot.
And Rousseau never made it.
And Rousseau actually got
attacked by a leopard once,
who managed to rip off half of
his scrotum, and Rousseau
survived that;
pretty amazing.
So this is the function--it's
sort of a hill-shaped or
hump-shaped function of success
versus group size,
with the best group size being
around five.
And then if you look at who
shares in the capture,
what you see is a breakdown
where there is considerable
sharing which is going on.
And you can see that
bystanders, who are often
females,
are eating meat often after a
capture for nearly half an hour,
and the captor usually gets
most of it.
But it's very interesting how
much gets shared.
And if you look at the kind of
hunt that was involved,
you can see interestingly,
if you classify the hunts by
kind of a primitive,
not terribly well-coordinated
hunt,
which is a half-anticipation,
through a single-anticipation
hunt,
where one of the chimps is
actually successfully
anticipating where the colobus
are going and manages to get
over and block them off,
to a doubled-anticipation hunt,
which is even more
sophisticated,
you can see that there is a
reward in terms of amount of
meat eaten for participating in
a more sophisticated hunt.
Okay?
They pay a tax,
and they are willing to pay a
tax to belong to the group.
The tax that they pay is by
sharing what they capture.
So there is an anticipation of
being willing to give up
personal gain for group benefit.
And there's another thing going
on here, and that is that quite
a bit of the reward of
bystanders is trading food for
sex.
So both taxes and prostitution
appear to be present in
chimpanzees.
Now what about learning?
Well this is the frequency of
ambushes that are used by
hunters of different ages.
Ambushing is,
you know, a moderately
sophisticated tactic.
It's not quite as sophisticated
as a big group hunt,
but it's an indication that,
you know, young chimps are
learning how to hunt.
And this is how old they are.
And the interesting thing about
this is--well of course they're
weaned at five;
so they aren't really going to
start participating until they
get there, and they don't do too
much hunting before they become
teenagers.
But then let's suppose they
start playing here,
they start going out and
hunting here.
It takes them until they're
thirty-five-years-old before
they really hit their peak.
It takes them about twenty
years to learn how to be an
effective hunter.
That's pretty amazing.
And if you look,
if you break this down by
half-anticipations and
full-anticipations,
what you see is the frequency
with which full-anticipations
are practiced in hunts is lower,
and it takes a long time before
they get up to the level of
half-anticipations.
So these are categories of
sophistication in hunting,
and it takes a long time to get
more sophisticated.
So to sum up on the behaviors
that are involved in foraging
and hunting, I've really given
you today two paradigms for how
to think about it.
One of them is the marginal
value theorem,
which tells you how you should
decide when to stop hunting in a
certain place,
or when to stop copulating in a
and go off to find either food
or mates in another place;
and that works in a spatial
situation where you have to move
some distance before you get to
the patch.
And the other paradigm that
I've given you is simply the
cost-benefit analysis of how
much caloric reward do I get out
of hunting in a group versus
hunting by myself?
And you can see that if you do
that cost-benefit analysis,
it turns out that organisms
don't do it perfectly,
but they do get better and
better at approximating the
optimal payoff.
So that tells us that hunting
is basically microeconomics.
It's a very short-term,
kind of selfish behavior,
where the group hunting
behavior, which looks like it
might not be so selfish,
in terms of caloric reward is
quite selfish,
and it looks like it's
long-term selfish.
So the sharing is stabilizing
relationships that are paying
off in terms of future hunts and
future sexual opportunities.
We've seen that predation is
shaping both the behavior and
the morphology of prey.
We saw that with both
conspicuous coloration,
aposematic coloration,
which is advertising the
presence of poisons;
and we saw it with crypsis,
which is cryptic coloration,
which is hiding and looking
like something else.
We saw that aggressive mimicry
illustrates an important
evolutionary trend,
which is that every available
opportunity will eventually be
seized by some species evolving
into that niche.
And we saw it with fireflies,
and then I told you about
cleaning wrasses in saber-tooth
blennies.
And then finally I showed you
the cooperative hunting,
complex example in chimpanzees.
It requires strategic thinking;
it requires a kind of teamwork
that really is only attained in
fairly complex organisms.
I'll mention one other,
which is deeply cool,
and that is the bubble-nets of
humpback whales.
Who has heard of a humpback
whale bubble-net?
A few.
Humpback whales hunt in family
groups in Alaska and down near
Antarctica, and they hunt for
fish that are in schools.
They hunt herring.
And a mama humpback will go
down below a group of herring,
and she'll start up in a
spiral, just at the right rate,
so that the bubbles that she's
blowing out of her nose will all
rise up in a curtain to the
surface around the school of
herring at the same time;
so a curtain of bubbles,
that looks like a net,
is going up around the school
of herring.
And at the same time she gives
a few little signals with her
complex calling behavior,
and the whole family of whales
will dive down,
and they'll come up as a group
and they'll open their mouths
underneath the school of
herring,
and all of the mouths will
emerge from the water at the
same time.
They can take out an entire
school of herring with one bite
apiece.
They're taking in maybe two or
three tons of fish when they do
this;
like five or six whales doing
it all at once,
they're right next to each
other.
So there are very interesting
examples where other species,
that appear to have complex
cognition and good signaling
capacity,
learn really rather
sophisticated behavior.
And I think the chimpanzee hunt
is one of the most interesting.
I'm sorry it's so bloody,
and I do hope you enjoy your
lunch.